[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi est très
octobre ils fêtent leurs 50 ans les
parcs naturels régionaux de france donne
rendez vous au public parisien pour
découvrir leurs richesses ce week-end
qu'elles soient gastronomiques et
artisanales ou culturel le parc de la
haute vallée de chevreuse étaient
évidemment présents sur place isabelle
paoletti notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission chargée de mission au
sein de cap emploi 78 nous évoquerons
avec elle les problématiques pour
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en situation de handicap alors
que leur taux de chômage atteint 10 9%
en france enfin dans le reste de
l'actualité locale nous reviendrons sur
la fronde des départements franciliens à
propos de la métropole du grand paris ou
encore l'opération octobre rose pour le
dépistage du cancer du sein
un rendez vous donc à ne pas manquer ce
week-end si vous êtes un amoureux des
produits du terroir tous les parcs
naturels régionaux de france s'installe
le temps d'un week-end à paris dans le
12ème arrondissement pour faire
découvrir au grand public leurs
richesses culturelles les visiteurs
peuvent notamment investir le stand du
pnr de chevreuse un reportage de mickeal
et demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude la haute vallée de chevreuse en
opération séduction à paris depuis ce
jeudi 12 octobre un stand de s'y mettre
car est installé au sein de bercy
village dans le cadre de la première
édition de destination parc
un événement qui regroupe les 51 parcs
naturels régionaux de france
les parcs naturels régionaux ne sont pas
forcément très connu du grand public et
surtout des parisiens et puis parce que
les gens ne connaissent pas forcément
leur territoire et on s'est dit que
d'avoir un événement un peu grand public
pour sensibiliser les gens à
l'environnement à la découverte des
saveurs et des territoires c'est une
bonne occasion de le faire sur paris les
20 représentants du pnr de chevreuse
proposer des questionnaires sur leur
territoire mais également des
dégustations d'une douzaine de produits
régionaux
les visiteurs ont pu goûter du sirop de
chevreuse du fromage de la ferme de
coubertin du miel ou encore du jus de
poire de gambe et on est en relation
directe avec eux sachant qu'on travaille
à peu près tout année avec eux est sûre
evènement on essaye de valoriser leurs
produits nous proposer aux gens du jus
de pommes etc afin qu'ils se fassent
connaître
donc ceci fait un petit peu
naturellement en fait par rapport aux
liens qu'on a tout le temps avec eux
pour cette première journée des milliers
de visiteurs n'ont pas hésité à aller
sous la tente pour découvrir la haute
vallée de chevreuse je n'y suis jamais
allé je suis passé en voiture près mais
sans m'arrêter
c'est très bien moi je trouve que c'est
formidable ça nous permet de découvrir
des régions qu'on connaît pas
éventuellement si vous aussi vous voulez
découvrir de nouveaux parcs régionaux
l'événement est organisé jusqu'à ce
dimanche dans le 12e arrondissement de
paris puis de 60 mille personnes sont
attendues sur le site pendant ces quatre
jours de présentations les 262 mer des
yvelines avait rendez-vous cette année à
port marly pour leur traditionnelle
université l'occasion pour eux de faire
remonter les problématiques du terrain
et de se voir aussi exposer des
solutions pour les aider dans leur
développement un reportage de maxime le
maine pour le conseil départemental des
yvelines
l'université des mairies des yvelines
est l'occasion chaque année pour le
département de réaffirmer son
attachement et son soutien aux communes
l'organisation territoriale française
est bousculée et on a le sentiment que
le pouvoir central méprise les maires je
pèse mes mots en disant ça quand un
docteur en économie
conseiller les présents a révélé il dit
qu'il faut remplacer les maires ruraux
par des fonctionnaires comprenez que ça
ne peut pas plaire et vous
donc faire entendre la voix de la raison
parce qu'on est peut-être la france ceux
du passé pour certains je pense qu'on
est surtout la france éternelle un
message fort
entendu par liv linois président du
sénat gérard larcher
bien conscient des problématiques des
communes et à des sujets que j'ai
ressenti
les sujets par exemple de ce qu'on
baptise fracture numérique le sujet
aussi désertification médicale dans bon
nombre d'endroits et le sujet majeur des
mobilités des sujets auxquels le
département tente d'apporter des
solutions au travers de structures comme
hymne générique dédié à la ruralité
secteur qui cumule bon nombre de
problématiques afin d'accroître son
efficacité
le budget de l'agencé sera doublée en
2018 et son siège installé à rambouillet
j'encourage les maires à venir nous voir
bien sûr mais je m'encourage aller les
voir également parce que c'est important
d'être sur le terrain et de voir
l'évolution des projets de discuter avec
eux et de sentir la ruralité
enfin un geste fort en direction des
communes plus urbaine le président bédié
a annoncé que le département viendrait
en aide aux villes carencé autrement dit
celles qui n'ont pas suffisamment de
logements sociaux permettent et
favoriser l' embauche des personnes en
situation de handicap c'était l'ambition
du handi recrutement qui était organisée
à ce vendredi matin à l'hôtel de ville
de montigny le bretonneux une mise en
relation entre employeurs et
travailleurs handicapés avec la
participation notamment de cap emploi 78
nous allons revenir justement sur ce
rendez vous avec notre invité fil rouge
isabelle paoletti bonsoir vous êtes donc
chargée de mission emploi et handicap au
sein de cap emploi 78 un organisme dédié
à l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes handicapées
vous étiez présente vous même ce
vendredi matin l'hôtel de ville de
montigny le bretonneux
quel bilan vous vous tirez de ce on dit
recrutement est ce que employeurs et
travailleurs se sont rencontrés
efficacement alors à chaud le premier
bilan
très positive c'est à dire que donc
comme d'habitude on organise en
collaboration avec pôle emploi avec la
mairie avec cap emploi cet événement on
a reçu 13 entreprises qui avaient des
offres diverses et variées à destination
de personnel personnes en situation de
handicap et ça s'est très bien passé
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de rencontres
ça c'est le bilan à chaud à peu près 150
personnes reçues qui ont qui ont
rencontré les entreprises on verra plus
tard en fait s'il ya eu deux déçus les
embauches qui ont été générés etc
j'allais justement vous demander si
c'est vraiment efficace ce genre de
rendez-vous pour permettre la mise en
relation j'imagine que c'est cette
première étape la plus essentielle parce
que il ya souvent des suites positives
ou alors souvent les entreprises un peu
pour pour leurs images viennent se
montre présente mais ensuite ça coince
un petit peu alors il ya des
aboutissements n'y en a pas énormément
mais c'est pas grave parce que c'est
être extrêmement positif pour les
personnes qu'on suit c'est à dire que
c'est des personnes qui vont pouvoir
rencontrer directement l'entreprise qui
n'est pas forcément le cas si le cv n'a
pas passé le la première étape et qui
sont pas reçus et les entreprises vont
gommer un petit peu leur quelquefois
leurs idées préconçues l'heure c'est
plus un travail parfois à long terme
exactement je me rends travailleurs
aussi de prendre confiance en lui qui
est essentiel quand on quand on cherche
du boulot tout à fait et aux entreprises
d'être un peu moins frileuse par rapport
au handicap
le fait de les mettre en lien en contact
dans un contexte fort convivial c'est
une très bonne idée même si
l'aboutissement n'est pas forcément 50
emplois alors l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes en
situation de handicap reste une
problématique majeure en france on va
donner quelques chiffres
trente ans après la fameuse loi du 10
1987 qui oblige toutes les entreprises
de plus de 20 salariés à employer au
moins 6% de personnes handicapées trente
ans après cette loi le taux de chômage
justement dossier personnes en situation
de handicap atteint 19% c'est deux fois
plus que la moyenne nationale
quand on n'est pas habitué à voir un tel
chiffre forcément ça paraît effroyable
vous qui êtes on va dire un peu
spécialistes du domaine que diriez-vous
sur ce chiffre est ce que explique beth
est ce qu ils stagnent
est-ce que c'est plutôt positif et une
évolution positive qu'en est-il
concrètement de la situation alors je
dirais qu'il ya effectivement une
évolution positive même si effectivement
comme vous le dites on part de loin
le fait que le handicap soit de plus en
plus reconnu qu'on ait des lois quand
même qu'il soit fait pour essayer de de
mettre en place des aménagements par
exemple pour les personnes handicapées
qui sont en embauche on c'est
extrêmement positif mais effectivement
on a quand même un taux très important
on a aussi des personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap qui ne sont pas
toujours forcément au moment t aptes à
l'emploi il ya des aménagements à faire
enfin c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
il faut que l'entreprise est aussi le
l'ouverture et la patience de s'adapter
à la personne handicapée peut être alors
une question importante mais qui n'est
pas forcément clair pour tout le monde
quand on parle de travailleurs en
situation de handicap alors le premier
réflexe c'est peut-être de penser à la
personne en chaise roulante pu mais
finalement c'est c'est beaucoup plus
diverse que ça il peut y avoir la
personne qui a gravement malo au dos à
l'épaule
expliquez-nous un peu de qui on parle
c'est effectivement il ya énormément de
personnes qui à un moment ou un autre
dans leur vie de toute manière vous
rencontrez une situation de handicap qui
sera peut-être ponctuelle c'est à dire
que les maux de dos les mots des pôles
de coude etc
il ya énormément de personnes qui
connaissent ça il ya malheureusement des
personnes qui sont allées peut-être trop
loin déjà dans l'emploi et qui ont cette
ce handicap qui s'est installée et qui
ont une reconnaissance de travailleur
handicapé
et puis il ya tous les autres ont du cap
les handicaps sensoriels
allez les maladies invalidantes les
maladies il ya divers handicaps et c'est
vrai qu'on voit la personne en fauteuil
dans la rue on s'est calé handicap mais
la plupart des handicaps sont
effectivement complètement invisible
alors pour revenir aussi sur ce sujet
des 10 9% de chômeurs de travailleurs
handicapés
c'est un sujet qui je suis sûr
nécessiterait des heures et des heures
d'émission mais quels sont aujourd'hui
les les explications à un tel taux 19%
est ce que ce sont encore vous le disiez
les prérequis d des entreprises
est ce que c'est un problème de
formation peut être ni ne répond pas à
la demande et des entreprises est ce
qu'il ya un problème de mobilité
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui ne fonctionne
pas aujourd'hui en france quand on est
10 9 % de travailleurs handicapés au
chômage alors les aménagements sont pas
toujours mis en place en entreprise elle
sera puissant pour une entreprise
d'embaucher une personne pour laquelle
elle aura aucun aménagement à faire dans
les locaux ou sur le poste donc ça peut
s'expliquer les choses évoluent quand
même au fur et à mesure on fait un gros
travail de d'informations aussi auprès
des entreprises pour essayer d'adapter
et de leur expliquer qu'on a des
personnes qui à compétences égales sont
tout à fait en capacité de remplir les
postes
peut-être que yao qui encore beaucoup
beaucoup d'informations à faire et puis
expliquer qu'on peut aménager de manière
assez facile un poste pour plus
qu'intéressante d'aménagement par
exemple est-ce que vous avez aussi là un
exemple à nous donner
ben tu ne serait-ce qu'une par exemple
la personne qui en fauteuils bas
effectivement il faudra peut-être une
rampe pour qu'elles puissent accéder il
faudra une place pour travailleurs
handicapés c'est des choses qui évolue
ça devient de plus en plus obligatoire
donc les établissements recevant du
public normalement devrait avoir par
exemple une place pour une personne
handicapée pour se garer ça sera plus
accessible pour une personne de venir
déjà à l'entretien et de venir au
travail
c'est des choses qui doivent progresser
c'est perfectible certes mais on
progresse mais en avance mais une
question encore sur ceux sur la
législation ça fait 30 ans du coup que
ce taux des 6% a été fixé il n'est pas
atteint ni dans le public ni dans le
privé on a 3 % votre privé 5 dans le
public est-ce qu'il faut tout simplement
durcir cette loi est ce qu'il faut
augmenter le taux par exemple augmentent
les pénalités ce que vous vous en êtes
vous êtes favorable à ça est ce qu'il
faut une nouvelle loi plus dur alors je
vais être obligé de vous donner mon avis
à moi je pense que c'est pas en forçant
les choses qu'on arrivera à améliorer la
situation du de l'emploi pour les
personnes handicapées non c'est
l'information c'est la mise en compte
avec la mise en adéquation des besoins
et de et de l'offre c'est vraiment un
travail sur le terrain ce qu'on fait qui
au fur et à mesure vont faire progresser
les choses
alors on a évoqué la formation l'emploi
mais il y a une autre thématique
essentielle pour l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées
c'est évidemment la mobilité comment se
rendre au travail
comment se déplacer pour toutes les
activités banales du quotidien l'école
d'ingénieurs l'estaca située à montigny
le bretonneux organisé jeudi une journée
mobilité pour tous à destination de ses
étudiants reportage au premier coup
d'oeil on pourrait croire qu'il s'agit
d'un jet-ski un peu bricolé ever c'est
en fait un kite surf à voile pour des
skippers en situation de handicap
le projet était présenté pour la
première fois par l'association de voile
de l'estaca l'objectif c'était que de
créer un support qui est adapté pour les
audacieuses surtout pour les handicapés
mais du coup aussi pour les valides et
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi cette forme
parce que en fait avec le lacet halle
centrale d'inde jet ski c'est assez
adapté pour les handicapés pour qu'il
soit stable
la forme trimaran aussi parce que ça te
permet une grande stabilité sur l'eau la
présentation de ce prototype s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la première journée
mobilité pour tous organisée par l'école
une première pour sensibiliser les
ingénieurs de demain sur la
problématique du handicap de faire
rencontrer les étudiants et les
professionnels sur la thématique de la
mobilité et de
et la situation d'handicap dans la
mobilité pour
c'est un métier d'avenir c'est un métier
où la population vieillit il faudra
prendre de plus en plus en compte ces
difficultés de mobilité au sein de la
conception également de la production
atelier découverte conférences ou encore
animations sportives et est notamment
programmé pour cette journée spéciale
une journée qui a convaincu les
principaux intéressés
ça permet de
justement de casser ses idées reçues de
casser cette gêne vis-à-vis des pics
juste des gens tout à fait normaux qui
suit la malchance de se trouver dans ces
fauteuils ont animé des études ça fait
partie des sujets qu'on aborde pas
spécialement parce que c'est qu'une
petite partie des employés mais du coup
ils sont quand même là et c'est
important de savoir tout ce qui est mis
en oeuvre pour les intégrer
l'intégration professionnelle reste
encore une des problématiques
principales pour les personnes en
situation de handicap 19 % d'entre eux
sont au chômage aujourd'hui c'est deux
fois plus que la moyenne nationale
alors peut-être une réaction rapide sur
sur ce reportage est ce que c'est pas là
la clé finalement du problème plus de
communication plus peut-être
d'apprentissage auprès des auprès des
plus jeunes on a vu ces des étudiants
qui ont tous plus de 18 ans mais des
primaires dès le collège des lycées
faire faire de la pédagogie est ce que
c'est pas là aussi le la clé essentielle
pour pour résorber ses 19 % de chômage
bas on dit toujours intervenir c'est la
jeunesse je suis complètement d'accord
et plus en sensibilisera les les jeunes
et les enfants aux handicaps comme on le
fait par exemple pour la langue des
signes avec des tout petits et plus on
évoluera et et on arrivera vers le
l'emploi des personnes handicapées
général en tout cas là aussi sur ce
sujet vous êtes positif vous voyez les
jeunes évoluer leur regard sur le
handicap évoluer aussi positivement
exactement c'est à dire plus on présente
de manière naturelle à un enfant le
handicap en disant bas il ya des choses
qui marchent pas chez certaines
personnes
c'est pas grave elles ont d'autres
choses qu'elles ont développé et le les
enfants son approche de manière beaucoup
plus naturelle vers les personnes
handicapées et c'est vers ça qu'il faut
tondre au plus merci isabelle paoletti
d'être venu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes chargé de mission pour cap
emploi 78 merci à vous merci beaucoup à
vous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
et l'actualité de cette semaine marquée
notamment par la colère mardi des
présidents des sept départements
d'ile-de-france ensemble ils ont exprimé
leur inquiétude quant à l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris des annonces du
gouvernement sont attendus début
novembre sur le sujet les détails avec
ce reportage
c'est une image inhabituelle de la
politique francilienne les sept
présidents des départements de la région
assis côte à côte pour évoquer ensemble
un souci commun la métropole du grand
paris ce nouvel échelon territorial
créée il ya 18 mois qu'ils soient des
républicains socialistes ou communistes
ils veulent tous modifier le schéma de
la métropole une collectivité qu'il
estime néfaste pour les habitants de la
grande couronne exclus du périmètre
actuel en 2017 dans la république
française on veut faire un mur entre la
métropole riche la métropole riches pour
les riches et puis la grande couronne
qui l a tous les ennuis c'est compliqué
de venir à paris en voiture
c'est compliqué de venir à paris un
transport en commun on se déplace pas ce
qu'on va chercher de l'emploi
nous avons une ambition plus grande
pourquoi parce que nous estimons que
c'est le bon échelon la région métropole
non seulement pour traiter les problèmes
de vie quotidienne de nos habitants mais
aussi
dans la compétition internationale pour
faire face au grand londres plus grandes
et plus puissantes pour les départements
de la grande couronne moins envahissante
pour ceux de la petite couronne
val-de-marne hauts-de-seine et
seine-saint-denis et s'inquiète eu des
rumeurs concernant une suppression de
l'échelon départemental au profit de la
métropole les projets je mets en oeuvre
aujourd'hui je le fais sur la base d'un
mandat démocratique qui m'a été confié
par les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis que chacun de ceux qui
veulent se faire plus gros et bien fasse
la démonstration de ce soutien
démocratique ce n'est pas le cas je suis
favorable à une grande métropole à
caractère stratégique c'est-à-dire qu'il
travaille à l'attractivité de la région
parisienne dans son ensemble au plan
international mais pas à ce que la
métropole du grand paris s'occupe du
ramassage des ordures ménagères de la
gestion des crèches ou de des pmi
directement mis en cause l'exécutif
prévoit d'organiser début novembre une
conférence autour de l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris est d'ici là
les tensions elles pourraient continuer
de s'accroître
lundi la ministre des sports laura
flessel était en déplacement au château
de versailles l'ancienne championne des
scream s'est rendu sur les futurs sites
olympiques du château qui abritera
notamment les épreuves d'équitation et
de pentathlon moderne en 2024
reportage il n'y a encore que de l'herbe
avec une vue imprenable sur le château
de versailles dans quelques années
sept ans précisément les cavaliers et
leurs montures s'affronteront ici pour
les épreuves d'équitation djo laura
flessel la ministre des sports est venu
visiter les futurs sites olympiques du
château de versailles qui doit
accueillir également le pentathlon
moderne
on a cette chance de valoriser gérer le
château de versailles géré au niveau
international lors ce qu'on valait
partir à l'international va nous poser
des questions sur les lieux qui vont
recevoir les jeux et aujourd'hui le
château de versailles je connaissais
mais lorsqu'on a cette transposition et
et qu'on voit à gérer comment on va
utiliser gérer pour le futur on est
fiers déjà l'un des sites les plus
visités de france le château de
versailles profitera forcément de
l'effet jo
si les travaux n'ont pas débuté le
projet pas encore totalement arrêtée
des tribunes seront construites pour
accueillir jusqu'à 20000 personnes
de quoi craindre d'éventuelles
dégradations des lieux mais la direction
l'assuré rassure l'histoire du monument
sera préservé le cio s'engage évidemment
à respecter tout l'intégrité de ce lieu
je crois même que ça n'a pas fait la
moindre discussion pour personne quand
les membres du cio sont venus ici
il connaissait le château de versailles
il voyait que c'est ce lieu était resté
dans son intégrité depuis xviiie siècle
qu'on ne pouvait rien y changer
en plus du château de versailles le
département des yvelines accueillera
d'autres épreuves olympiques notamment
celle du cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
on referme cette page politique avec
benoît hamon qui a annoncé en début de
semaine qu'il quittait le groupe psa la
région ile de france où l'ancien
candidat socialiste à la présidentielle
rejoint les verts il est accompagné de
neuf autres élus dont sandrine legrand
gang première secrétaire fédérale du ps
dans les yvelines cet été déjà benoît
hamon avait quitté le parti socialiste
national et créer son propre mouvement
du 1er juillet mardi plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de fonctionnaires ont
manifesté à paris contre les mesures
prévues par le gouvernement suppression
de 120 mille postes en cinq ans gel des
salaires ou encore hausse de la csg
c'est la première fois en l'espace de
dix ans que tous les syndicats a appelé
à la mobilisation
écoutez à ce propos bertrand mesure
qu'au secrétaire départemental du
syndicat d'enseignants snuipp fsu il
répondait aux questions de notre
journaliste grégory canal et en direct
par téléphone c'était mardi écouter tu
crois que qui est caractéristique qu'en
termes la fonction publique fait que
manifestement le gouvernement souhaite
l'impact et l'intérêt général et la
fonction publique et l'impôt défendre et
pour participer à cet intérêt général
il vous a pas échappé que les dernières
mesures du gouvernement visait plus à
frapper
personnes dont ne font partie ni les
fonctionnaires ni les salariés en
général qui ceux du privé sont attaqués
particulièrement violemment concernant
la vie de la loi travail
alain buis le nouveau président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines était lui aussi en plateau
de tv 78 mardi et lui il y a une dizaine
de jours par le conseil d'administration
de l'établissement après la démission de
didier guillemot pour raisons de santé
alain buis a exposé son désir notamment
de rapprochement avec l'université de
paris saclay regarder lui énormément
d'atouts cette université de recherche
de très haute qualité de formation en
attestent les classements internationaux
alors selon certains critères évidemment
mais qui nous place parmi les le top 500
sur ce point de shanghai est au top 6
ans sur les deux années consécutives et
un autre classement
th et higher education skis forêt
heureux blessés dans ces classements là
on est à la place de 20e entre 20e
établissements français au 12e
établissements français donc c'est à
dire que lui est ce qu est très bien
positionné a beaucoup d'atouts pour ce
projet qui est extrêmement porteur pour
l'avenir
54 mille nouveaux cas détectés chaque
année en france le cancer du sein est le
plus meurtrier chez les femmes une femme
sur huit sera touchée par ce cancer au
cours de sa vie pourtant une détection
précoce permet de guérir à 90 % des
patientes et ce mois ci est
traditionnellement octobre rose un
moment de sensibilisation au dépistage
reportage justement au centre
hospitalier de versailles de mélanie
poquet et nicolas landry donc moi j'ai
oppermann
en juillet les narnia jo 2016
un petit cancer du sein en droit avec un
traitement conservateur consultations de
suivi pour cette patiente le cancer du
sein est le plus répandu des cancers
féminins
il touche une femme sur huit en france
il faut que la personne soit suivi c'est
ce qu'on leur conseille régulièrement
annuellement par leur gynécologue
traitant qui pratique un examen clinique
des seins examen mammaire puis un examen
gynécologique et qui peut soit dépistée
quelque chose soit en tout cas être
attentif aux facteurs nourrissent de la
patiente et d'adressé faire ça
mammographie et son échographie à titre
individuel ces deux praticiens reçoivent
conjointement des patients adressés par
des confrères après un premier examen
la palpation annuelle est la première
étape d'un dépistage
la mammographie elle permet de révéler
les tumeurs dépistage permet de
diagnostiquer des lésions très petit
qu'on appelle des lésions infraclinique
c'est à dire qu'elle ne pourrait pas
être perçu ni par la patiente elle même
y par un médecin lors d'un examen
c'est le
des visages mammographie qui permet de
détecter ces très petites lésions et qui
permet donc des prises en charge un
stade très précoce
chaque année 54 mille nouveaux cas sont
détectés en france une fois par semaine
à versailles oncologue médecin nucléaire
ou encore radiologue concernés se
rassemblent et on a discuté aujourd'hui
de medan d'une jeune patiente de 37 ans
qui s'est auto palper à nous du lait a
donc fait une mammographie comme les
nodules et est suspect et le radiologue
lui ai fait une biopsie et j'ai revu
avec les résultats de la biopsie qui est
retrouvé un cancer du sein
l'objectif de ces réunions sont
discutées de la prise en charge des
patients avec l'oeil des différents
spécialistes qui voit à chaque fois la
maladie sous un angle différent sur les
possibilités thérapeutiques dans le
domaine qui concerne justement le
médecin qui discutent du dossier
l'intérêt étant d'assurer la meilleure
prise en charge du patient
les médecins du centre hospitalier de
versailles opère une centaine de
patients chaque année un cancer détecté
à un stade précoce peut être guéri dans
9 cas sur 10 en 2016 seule une femme sur
deux se faisait des pistes et jeudi les
fans de foot avaient rendez-vous à
poissy pour assister à un match de gala
du variétés club de france organisé au
profit de deux associations le match a
permis de récolter 15 mille euros sur la
pelouse étaient présents didier
deschamps laurent blanc alain giresse ou
encore le joueur du psg
hatem ben arfa c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo autour de l'information en
direct lundi à 18 heures d'ici là restez
informés connectés grâce à notre site
internet et nos applications tv 78 bon
et cannes à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]